Nelda valeros and her family have hardly
been able to sleep for nearly a week
they live in the coast of Paula in one
of several towns where oil from a sunken
tanker has washed the shore
the smell makes us want to vomit our
heads hurt and we've also been coughing
it's been especially hard on my 15 year
old child
Tuesday a carrying 800 000 liters of
unrefined oil suffered engine trouble
and sunk off mindoro in the central
Philippines The Spill has reached a
neighboring Island and could drift even
farther if it isn't contained
the waters around here are some of the
most pristine in the Philippines a
number of areas are Marine protected
which means even fishing isn't allowed
but at the moment as you can see water
along this Coast is black
53 year old manuelo acebeda has been a
fisherman almost all his life but all he
can do now is look out to the Sea
fishing has been banned indefinitely and
it's already taking a toll on its
livelihood
[Music]
especially because we have children who
go to school
all they can do now is help coast guards
clean up the beaches so they might be
able to get to see quicker but they say
the pollution is getting worse by the
day
after we clean up they'll come again
especially when the waves are high we
clean non-stop they come Non-Stop
the government has promised to provide
aid but those who are being affected say
while they appreciate any help that
could tie them over what they really
want is to have their way of life back
as soon as possible
point below Al Jazeera Oriental mindoro
the Philippines